- Hey it's me again.
First thing I want to
tell you is I don't drink
and I don't recommend drinking alcohol,
alright so in this video we're going
to talk about the liver, specifically how
to reverse a fatty liver.
Couple facts about the liver.
The liver is about
three and a half pounds,
it's huge it's on the
right side of your body.
It goes all the way up here
and it's right through here.
Okay, it has over 500 functions.
It does everything from immune control,
digestion, detoxification of chemicals,
building up of proteins,
it does so many things.
It's an amazing, miraculous organ.
It has 50,000 to 100,000
small little units
of cells that help do the work.
You really could be
functioning pretty good
in your body and have 90% of your liver
destroyed or dysfunctional.
So a lot of times the
liver will not show up
until greater than 90% of it's destroyed.
So you can't always go how
you feel with the liver.
But some of the symptoms
with a real bad liver issue
is you get bloating,
you have right shoulder
pain through here, the whites
of your eyes turn yellow,
there's a lot of skin
issues, itching of the bottom
of the feet and the palms of the hand,
basketball belly like
you're protruding belly.
But you can really predict the health
of the liver by the
person's lifestyle habits.
So there's several stages
of liver damage that occur.
The first one is from inflammation.
Inflammation where it
could come from a virus
but it also could come
from bad eating or alcohol.
So every time you drink
it creates a trauma,
kind of a whiplash because you're killing
liver cells when you're doing that.
Every time you take Tylenol or medication
you kill liver cells.
So it has a lot of damage.
Even some of the medications like Lipitor,
for example, will
severely stress the liver
and increase the liver enzymes by 500%.
So one of the big side effects.
The medication is supposed
to lower your cholesterol
which basically has
everything to do with liver,
ends up destroying your liver.
It's kind of insane.
So you have an inflammatory condition.
Then you have fatty deposits
that lodge into the liver,
so over time the liver
can be replaced with fat.
Many people with bellies out
to here have a fatty liver.
If they just had an ultrasound they would
be able to identify that.
But it's very hard to detect
chronic liver problems
unless you do a biopsy because it doesn't
always show up on a blood test.
So over time when you have
this inflammatory state
of continuing damage on the
liver because of bad habits,
you develop scar tissue and that leads
into something called cirrhosis.
Cirrhosis is the liver that is filling up
with fibrous tissue that's
making it dysfunctional
and you lose the function of the liver.
But again you can get away
with only a small portion
of liver working before you even notice
a lot of the symptoms so just because
you are feeling it doesn't mean anything.
Alright, so that's what
happens with the liver.
When the liver swells up because there's
not a lot of space it could put pressure
on the heart and create a lot
of heart arrhythmia issues,
a lot of skipped beats, it can
create high blood pressure,
increase pulse rate, why?
Because the liver is
right next to the heart
and it's going to compress on the heart.
When the person sleeps on their left side
if they have an enlarged liver,
it will compress the
heart and make it hard
to breathe and sleep at night.
So liver cases tend to
sleep better on the right
side of their body than the left.
So that's one thing.
Secondly is the liver is
one of the only organs
in the body that can
completely 100% regenerate.
That's the good news.
The bad news is it takes a long time
to regenerate the liver cells.
It could take up to three years.
But I think the worst
recommendation for people
is everything in moderation
because you cannot
heal the liver having a
moderate amount of junk food
to the diet because again if
you're drinking every night
or every other day or even once a week
it could take you one,
two, three, four days
for that liver to recover and so you
never really let it recover.
So it's the accumulation of
letting the liver recover
and heal that helps it regenerate.
So it takes a long time.
I had someone do my
liver enhancement program
and they lost all this
weight but they had called
me up and said Dr. Berg
your liver enhancement
doesn't work because I
did it for two weeks,
I lost the weight and
then the weight came back.
Come to find out in
their mind they thought
they were going to heal
the liver in two weeks.
That was a miscalculation.
They need to do it for a lot
longer until that liver heals.
So that's one thing.
So what we want to do
is we want to eliminate
the things that are destroying the liver.
Now alcohol is probably the top thing
that destroys the liver and I do not agree
with so called
recommendations that you can
get away with drinking every night.
That does not work, it
creates damage on the liver.
I don't want to get into that,
I think that's kind of common sense
but what I want to tell you is what to do
to get this fat out of the liver.
Number one stop the
things that are destroying
the liver and add the things that
will create a healthy liver.
One of the most powerful
things that will do it
are the bitter vegetables, the
ones that don't taste good.
The more bitter the better
like the collar greens,
mustard greens, the kales, the spinaches,
those are really good
for liver regeneration.
The radishes are really good for the liver
and you have to start consuming
those on a regular basis.
So the other thing is that the liver does
not do well with deep fried foods,
but it does need certain oils.
The types of fats that
are good for the liver
are the medium chain triglycerides.
Now what does that mean?
Like the coconut oils.
The coconut oil is one of the best things
as far as the fat to
cook in and to consume
to help a liver because it doesn't seem
to strain the liver at all.
It takes the stress off the liver.
The ones that destrain the liver are like
the corn oils that you
would buy at the store
or of course the hydrogenated oils.
Those are really really bad.
So we want a healthy liver.
Butter is actually a medium
chain triglyceride too
so that would be okay to consume
and that takes the stress off the liver.
So bitter vegetables,
the other thing that's
really good for the liver to clean out
some of the toxic waste
would be apple cider vinegar
and some of your water.
So if you take like a teaspoon
of apple cider vinegar,
put it in your water and consume that
a few times a day, that is really good
to strip off the fat off of that liver.
So as you consume these
vegetables over time
that have a lot of the B vitamins too,
especially like vitamin
B2, choline, folate,
all those key B vitamins that help
the liver regenerate, over time the liver
will get better and better
and better and better
but you're just going to have to not drink
or not drink so much.
One of the replacements that I like
for the alcohol would be the kombucha tea.
You can get it from the health food store.
Kombucha tea creates a
similar effect to alcohol.
You feel very relaxed and calm and again
people drink to relax so
that would be one substitute
and it's really good for the liver.
But the main thing is the vegetables.
In this product I have it's called
the whole cruciferous food.
I created a blend of the garlic, turmeric,
radish, brussell sprouts,
kale, cabbage, parsley.
Parsley has the most vitamin A,
the most nutrition of any vegetable
and number two is kale.
Kale is not quite as strong as parsley
but it's easier to consume
kale in the kale shake
so I recommend at least one
kale shake for your liver.
But this is a good combination
of cruciferous vegetables.
For those people that
cannot consume that amount
of vegetables and they
need some supplement
type help with the liver.
So those are some tips on
reversing a fatty liver,
it's doable but you have to
take aggressive approach,
you have to keep creating the liver,
give it time, have patience,
that's why we call you a patient.
I'm being sarcastic and so go ahead
and do that and I will
see you in the next video.